les battues physiquement vous voyez le
poids arrive et quand vous êtes battus
psychologiquement vous voyez pas toi et
surtout entendu si vous n'êtes pas
prévenu si on ne savait pas ce qui se
passe c'est l'autre visage de la
violence conjugale celui qui ne se voit
pas les coups au moral harcèlement
insultes menaces la reconnaissance des
atteintes psychologiques dans le couple
a été plus lente elle n'en est pas moins
violente
la parole était rare avant les années
2000 il y a tout de même cette femme
en 1975 elle décrit le calvaire que lui
fait vivre son mari les coûts mais
surtout la pression quotidienne
j'étais obligé le graff et comme il a
désiré de m'habiller comme il voulait de
ne rien faire
en dehors des luys en quoi j'ai été
soumise à des sanctions
1989 autre témoignage celui du bois
morales ont détruit alors ou détruit une
femme en lui jetant des horreurs à la
figure les bleus les hématomes les
plaies c'est la partie visible de la
violence dans le couple les violences
conjugales constitue un délit depuis
1994 mais rien pour les femmes brisées
de l'intérieur
à défaut de loi au début des années 2000
le tissu associatif agit sur tout le
territoire
il s'agit d'aider des victimes qui n'ont
souvent pas conscience de la spirale qui
les engloutit ça commence par des
violences verbales des insultes des
violences psychologiques au fond qui
tendent à nier l'autre comme autres la
femme n'est plus rien ne devient plus
rien et la honte et la culpabilité elle
la prend sur elle pour que le
gouvernement se saisisse de la question
il faut attendre 2009 année où les
violences conjugales devienne grande
cause nationale
c'est une avancée considérable parce que
la création de ce délit va permettre de
prendre en compte les situations les
plus sournoises la loi spécifique aux
violences psychologiques et votée en
2010 reste une difficulté prouvées de
tels agissements la députée chantal
brunel appelle les victimes et les
proches à recueillir témoignages
enregistrement sms et mail mais cette
loi elle la présente avant tout comme
dissuasive
c'est pour prévenir le mari le conjoint
violent qui peut pas se permettre d'
humilier sa femme régulièrement en 2010
la violence psychologique conjugale
devient un délit passible de trois ans
de prison et de 75000 euros d'amendé
texte prévoit aussi la sensibilisation
des policiers et magistrats
jusque là peu dotées face à des femmes à
la douleur sourde
[Musique]